my dangerous idea is that we should
legalize all of the currently illegal
drugs not just marijuana but cocaine
heroin methamphetamine LSD everything
else that's out there my basic argument
is that first in a free society
we should allow people to consume
whatever they want no matter how
dangerous no matter how much it might be
bad for them because that's what freedom
means not just the freedom to do things
that are good for you but the freedom to
do things that might not be good for you
or that other people might think are not
good for you
second by trying to discourage people
using drugs and try and discourage the
genuine unfortunate circumstances which
happens sometimes because of drug use we
under far worse negative outcomes far
worse cost than would result simply from
the use of drugs in a legal framework so
what are all these adverse consequences
of attempting to prohibit drugs well to
begin with we don't actually eliminate
drugs we drive the market underground
and the underground market for drugs is
violent it's corrupt it has poor quality
control and the attempt to enforce it we
have to infringe civil liberties by
basically shredding the Fourth Amendment
to the Constitution we reduce the
ability of people who are sick to use
drugs like marijuana or opiates freely
to reduce pain to relieve nausea from
chemotherapy and a whole range of other
symptoms we interfere in other countries
the violence that we observe in Mexico
the profitability underlying the Taliban
in Afghanistan all those result from the
fact that we've driven drug markets
underground and so terrorist groups make
a profit by selling their protection
services to the drug traffickers the
drug traffickers get the protection and
the terrorists get profits so that's
another ancillary cost of trying to wage
the war on drugs so my view is that if
we had a fully legal market for all of
these substances we would observe
roughly the same set of things we
observe now for alcohol for caffeine for
tobacco for other products which can be
dangerous
we would see a large fraction of people
use them in moderation use them
reasonably responsible with it most mild
negatives for themselves or for others
we would see a small fraction who would
misuse them in bad ways but mainly
would adversely affect themselves not
the rest of society and that that's a
far better balance in no way shape or
form a solution in the sense of
eliminating all negatives but a far
better balance in the current policy of
trying to prohibit drugs
well people differ on exactly what
auxilary policies they might suggest
under a legalized drug regime virtually
everyone thinks that we would have
approximately the same auxilary policies
that we now have safer alcohol we have a
minimum purchase age might be 18 might
be 21 something like that we would have
restrictions on time and place of use so
that of course be driving under the
influence laws there might be
restrictions on using drugs while
operating heavy machinery and things
like that but all of that would be very
similar to what we currently do for
alcohol and all of that would be in a
framework where the overall use the
overall production transportation
distribution and possession would be
fully legal activities as occurs now for
alcohol or tobacco
so it's entirely possible perhaps even
likely that consumption of the illegal
drugs would increase hey if we legalized
the evidence doesn't suggest a very big
increase indeed some aspects of the
evidence don't suggest much increase at
all the Netherlands have roughly a legal
regime for marijuana not fully
technically legal but a far less
restrictive regime in the United States
their use rates are actually below those
in the United States
Portugal decriminalized all drugs not
just marijuana about 10 years ago and
they did not observe any significant
increases in use in some cases they saw
mild decreases in use so it's certainly
possible that use would go up the strong
likelihood is that much of that increase
would be from people who would use
responsibly but people who want to use
irresponsibly the ones who are willing
to violate the law to risk being
convicted of a felony and going to jail
they're already consuming and so the
increase in use weren't going to observe
if any is going to be moderate and mild
and therefore not a danger either to the
people consuming or for the most part to
anyone else
[Music]